This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个 iHeart 播客。有据可查的人类。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、体能和韧性的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上搜索 TWO percent。在 Look Back at it 播客中。从1979年开始，对我来说那是重要的一刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何度过难关的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是个疯狂的年份。那真是个疯狂的年份。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听 Look Back At It。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听 Learn the Hard Way，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖恩斯。这个节目聚焦黑人男性的经历，进行坦诚的对话，这些对话在其他任何地方进行其实都不太安全，但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着一套铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你非得这么做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听 Learn the Hard Way。2023年，《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，这份特定的检测报告你伪造过两次，对吗？我伪造了一次检测报告。这需要一大批互联网侦探出动，才能揭开一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个男同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello, everybody.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是 Love Trapped。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听 Love Trapped 播客。大家好。
Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode. as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. It is a pretty wild thought to realize that we have more information at our fingertips than any generation ever before. We are more in touch, any terrible news story, any terrible tragedy,
欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到播客节目。新听友、老听友，无论你们身处世界的哪个角落。很高兴你们能回来收听新的一集。当然，我们要剖析的是二十多岁的心理学。意识到我们指尖掌握的信息比以往任何一代人都多，这种想法着实有点疯狂。我们与外界的联系更加紧密，任何糟糕的新闻报道，任何惨烈的悲剧，
any groundbreaking discovery, niche profile piece, like we can access that from our phones at any hour in any instance. and it's great in many, many ways. We are very informed people, but it is quite frankly, not something that humans have necessarily evolved to deal with. I was watching this YouTube video the other day. Very, very random.
任何划时代的发现、小众的人物专题报道，我们在手机上随时随地都能获取。在很多很多方面，这都很棒。我们都是消息灵通的人，但坦白说，这并不是人类在进化过程中必然能够应付得来的。前几天我在看这个 YouTube 视频。非常非常随机。
It's going to sound strange, but it was like a day in the life of a medieval peasant, and I was watching this video, and I was thinking, this individual would have only had to worry about the world that was 10 to 20 kilometers, around him or her. They would only have the information given to them by the church or by their neighbors or by whoever, their king, their queen. They didn't know what was going on halfway across
听起来可能很奇怪，但那是关于中世纪农民一天的生活，我看着这个视频，心想，这个人只需要关心以他或她为中心方圆10到20公里以内的世界。他们所拥有的信息仅限于教堂、邻居、或是任何人、他们的国王、他们的女王所传达给他们的。他们根本不知道远在半个
the world in Persia or Rome and how that would affect them. They didn't know about the natural disasters in Asia or Africa or like the discoveries in Australia. It seemed almost a lot simpler that way and it is such a privilege to have access to the information that we have now, and it's definitely improved the ways in which we are very conscious global citizens, but it has its downsides. And as people in our 20s, we are one of the first generations to have grown up this way. We have grown up always having this constant information source in the palm of our hands, and it's given rise to this phenomenon known as doom scrolling.
世界之外的波斯或罗马发生了什么，也不知道那会如何影响他们。他们不知道亚洲或澳洲的自然灾害，也不知道澳洲的发现。那样似乎要简单得多，能够接触到我们现在拥有的信息是一种极大的特权，它绝对改善了我们成为非常具有意识的全球公民的方式，但它也有阴暗面。作为二十多岁的人，我们是第一批这样长大的人之一。我们在成长过程中，手中始终握着这个源源不断的信息源，这就催生了一种被称为“末日滚动”（doom scrolling）的现象。
Doomscrolling has a few meanings, but at its core, it is when we accidentally or consciously spend way too much time consuming online negative content, whether it is news articles, news contents about tragedies and terrors, or just actually hateful content, like nastiness in any form on the internet, you know, seeing mean comments, seeing cruel videos that are constantly like somehow thrown in our face by the algorithm that is not policed. This has a very deep yet, I would say hidden emotional and psychological consequence for us. And we all know that we don't feel very good when we spend too much time online. But I think we also need to get better at labeling why that is and controlling the reasons why we do it anyways. You know, despite feeling
末日滚动有几种含义，但其核心是，当我们不经意间或刻意花太多时间消费网上的负面内容时，无论是新闻文章、关于悲剧和恐怖事件的新闻内容，还是纯粹充满恶意的内容，比如互联网上任何形式的恶劣言论，你知道的，看到恶毒的评论，看到那些不断通过不受监管的算法不知怎的塞到我们面前的残酷视频。这给我们带来了非常深远却又可以说是隐藏的情绪和心理后果。我们都知道，花太多时间上网让我们感觉不太好。但我认为，我们还需要更擅长给这种现象贴上标签，找出原因，并控制我们无论如何都要去做的原因。你知道的，尽管觉得
like all this dark, terrible, horrible news content is making us feel worse about ourselves, we often can't stop and I'm one of those people. I know that this is going to make my mental state worse, but I cannot look away. I keep looking for new information. In part, I think that it's because we are addicted to our phones, but also there is this element of seeking out more information is a way that we soothe ourselves. And in this day and age, like when everything is quite stressful and you know there are a lot of reasons to feel unhappy about the world by scrolling on our phones and using social media that is a form of distraction from those feelings but it can also end up meaning that we are more constantly exposed to situations that are honestly quite harmful to be
所有这些黑暗、糟糕、可怕的新闻内容让我们对自己感觉更糟，我们往往还是停不下来，我就是那种人。我知道这会让我的精神状态变糟，但我无法移开视线。我一直在寻找新的信息。部分原因，我认为是我们对手机上瘾了，但也有这样一个因素：寻找更多信息是我们自我安慰的一种方式。在这个时代，当一切都相当令人压力山大，而且你知道有很多理由对世界感到不开心时，通过刷手机和使用社交媒体，那是从这些感受中分散注意力的一种形式，但它最终也可能意味着我们更加持续地暴露在那些说实话一直看下去相当有害的情况下。
viewing all the time we also then feel this like obligation right like i want to be informed I want to know what's going on. You can kind of see the trap that we're falling into. It's the same formula for any toxic habit. It is both like the devil and our savior. Doom scrolling and like reading the news or being informed makes us feel better for a second. And then it makes us feel worse. And then we try to feel better by going back and scrolling some more.
而且我们也会感到这种义务，对吧，就像我想了解情况。我想知道发生了什么。你可以看出我们正陷入的陷阱。这和任何有毒习惯的公式如出一辙。它既像是魔鬼，又像是我们的救世主。末日滚动以及阅读新闻或了解最新情况，让我们感觉好了一秒钟。然后又让我们感觉更糟。接着我们试图通过回去继续刷手机来让自己感觉好点。
And we get back to the same place that we started. So today I want to focus. in specifically on a rise in doom scrolling, how it has been slowly changing our brains and how we think about the world, especially as people in our 20s, and what we can kind of do about it. You know, we are seeing all these consequences, but we also don't want to be someone who is out of touch. We want to know what's going on. So how do we get into a healthy space and a healthy place with scrolling, with the news, with
然后我们又回到了原点。所以今天我想把重点专门放在末日滚动的兴起上，它如何慢慢改变了我们的思维方式以及我们对世界的看法，特别是作为二十多岁的人，以及我们对此能做些什么。你知道，我们看到了所有这些后果，但我们也不想成为一个与世隔绝的人。我们想知道发生了什么。那么，我们如何才能与刷手机、看新闻、
accessing the internet whatever it is what are the alternatives i'm very excited for this episode this is something that i personally needed to hear about i know that there is like a lot of just a lot of tension and stress and like political angst in the world at the moment understandably and this is an important topic to talk about in this time because when we speak about mental health it is a huge contributor so without further ado my lovely listeners let's get into the psychology of doom scrolling So, doom scrolling, we have a definition already. It's basically when we spend an excessive time consuming or being shown negative news content or online content that ultimately makes us feel pretty pessimistic. But it's also a really new term and it was coined during the pandemic. So I'm sure we all clearly remember how we were glued to our phones for any type of news or updates to do with lockdowns, case numbers, vaccine. rollout during that time during like 2020 to 2021. I have very distinct memories actually of checking the case numbers in my area,
访问互联网等建立一个健康的空间和状态，有什么替代方案？我对这一集非常兴奋，这是我个人需要了解的事情。我知道目前世界上有很多紧张、压力和政治焦虑，这是可以理解的，在这个时期这是一个重要的话题，因为当我们谈论心理健康时，这是一个巨大的促成因素。废话不多说，我可爱的听友们，让我们进入末日滚动的心理学。所以，对于末日滚动，我们已经有了一个定义。它基本上是指我们花大量时间消费或被推送负面新闻内容或在线内容，最终让我们感到相当悲观。但这也是一个非常新的词，它是在大流行期间创造的。所以我确信我们都清楚地记得，在2020年至2021年期间，我们是如何全神贯注于手机，以获取任何类型的与封锁、病例数、疫苗相关的突发新闻或更新。其实我有着非常清晰的记忆，那就是检查我所在地区的病例数，
like in my city, three, four, five, ten times a day to see if they'd gone down and reading every article, reading any press release that could potentially tell me that numbers were decreasing or we like had a cure, which neither of those things were never true. So basically during that time, research. as a little psychologist were seeing that because everything was so unknown and so scary, we just wanted as much information as we could get. We just wanted to know more. It was very soothing in a strange way.
比如在我所在的城市，一天检查三、四、五、十次，看看它们是否下降了，阅读每一篇文章，阅读任何可能告诉我数字在下降或者我们有了治疗方法的通告，而这两件事其实从来都不是真的。所以基本上在那段时间里，研究人员作为一个年轻的心理学家看到，因为一切都是那么未知，那么可怕，我们只是想要尽可能多的信息。我们只是想知道更多。从奇怪的角度来看，这非常具有抚慰作用。
But we also had all this empty time and space to consume more and more social media content than ever before. And we were taking full advantage of that. And these two kind of factors are what led to Doomscrow. is what led to people just feeling completely overwhelmed by some of the content that they were accessing. Now, obviously, we are no longer actively in a pandemic, but there are still a lot of things that have taken place in, you know, the last few months. It's ironic. I'm literally recording this like a week after the U.S. election, and I'm sure a lot of us are doomscrolling at the moment and will be in the next few months. But if you want some numbers around just how common this is, a 2024 survey that interviewed 5,000 American adults who are pretty good sample size, found that about 31% of adults will doomscroll on a regular basis.
但我们也有了所有的空闲时间和空间，去消费比以往任何时候都多的社交媒体内容。我们正在充分利用这一点。这两种因素导致了末日滚动。这也是导致人们被接触到的一些内容彻底压垮的原因。现在，很显然，我们已经不再处于大流行之中了，但在过去几个月里，仍然发生了很多事情。真讽刺。我录制这期节目的时候，正好是在美国大选后的一周左右，我确信我们很多人现在都在进行末日滚动，并且在接下来的几个月里也会如此。但如果你想要一些关于这有多普遍的数据，2024年的一项调查采访了5000名美国成年人，这是一个相当不错的样本量，发现大约31%的成年人会定期进行末日滚动。
But this percentage is a lot bigger, the younger you are. So for millennials, it's 46%. For Gen Z, it's 51%. That's half of us, half of us. And honestly, you know, I'm not even surprised by that number, considering all the people I talk to who are like, yeah, of course I feel really burdened by this. Of course I can't stop as well. It's a very, very common thing. Something we have got to take note of here, though, before we go any further, is that there are actually two types of doom scrolling. There is passive and active. So the passive doom scroll is when you can't, you know, you're not really going in search of any more information.
但这个比例越大，你越年轻。对于千禧一代来说，这个比例是46%。对于Z世代来说，是51%。那是我们的一半，我们的一半人。老实说，你知道，考虑到我交谈过的所有那些说“是的，当然，我感到压力很大。当然我也停不下来”的人，我对这个数字甚至并不感到惊讶。不过，在我们继续深入之前，我们需要注意的一点是，实际上有两种类型的末日滚动。有被动的，也有主动的。所以，被动的末日滚动是当你无法，你知道的，你并没有真正去寻找更多信息。
you're not seeking out negative news. You may not even be on like a news website, but you find it anyway, especially on Instagram, especially on TikTok or Twitter, whatever it is. We have like in our normal environments, we have semi like a little bit of control over what we see. Like when you're in your home, you get to choose the furniture, you get to choose the people that you invite in, you get to choose all those things, you know, you have a way of controlling your environments and based on your preferences and based on what you like. When you go online, you do not have that control.
你没有在寻找负面新闻。你甚至可能不在新闻网站上，但你还是遇到了，尤其是在Instagram上，尤其是TikTok或Twitter上，无论是什么。我们在正常环境中，对我们看到的东西拥有半点，一点点的控制权。就像你在家里一样，你可以选择家具，你可以选择你邀请进来的人，你可以选择所有这些事情，你知道的，你有一种根据你的偏好和你的喜好来控制环境的方法。当你上网时，你没有这种控制权。
You have no control over what you're going to see. Even if you try and train your algorithm to be suited to what you want to consume, about one third of us, according to a recent study by the National Institute of Health, we get our news online, even when we don't follow news sites because it pops up because it's the thing that is noteworthy because lots of people interact with that content. And I think even that is shocking in its own right, a third of us using social media as our primary news source. But that's kind of the day and age that we are in. And news sites and newspapers have adapted to that.
你无法控制你会看到什么。尽管你尝试并训练你的算法来适应你想消费的内容，但根据国家卫生研究院最近的一项研究，大约三分之一的人，我们从网上获取新闻，即使我们不关注新闻网站，因为它会弹出来，因为它值得关注，因为很多人与该内容互动。我认为仅仅这一点本身就令人震惊，我们中有三分之一的人将社交媒体作为主要新闻来源。但这正是我们所处的时代。新闻网站和报纸也已经适应了这一点。
And I guess it's better than nothing. But it's not just news, right? It's not just the news. It's watching an Instagram reel and opening the comments and seeing all the trolls. It is the videos that are toxic or mocking or mean. that also leaves a negative mark, especially considering how high a lot of our screen times are at the moment. You know, if you spend two to three hours on social media a day, which is the average amount that people spend, a lot of stuff is going to be filtering through.
我想这总比没有好。但这不仅是新闻，对吧？不仅仅是新闻。是看着Instagram短视频并打开评论区，看到所有的喷子。是那些有毒的、嘲讽的或卑鄙的视频，这也留下了负面印记，特别是考虑到我们目前的屏幕使用时间有多高。你知道，如果你一天花两到三个小时在社交媒体上，这是人们花费的平均时间，很多东西都会被过滤进来。
A lot of stuff that, you know, can you just imagine this? It's like you're scrolling. You're like, oh, beautiful, picture of my friend, picture of a celebrity, picture of a puppy, 20 dead in Lanslide. that is still information that is coming into your brain. So that's passive. The second type of doom scrolling is active doom scrolling, and it's what we typically think of when I say doom scrolling. It's like more of a conscious habit of constantly scrolling through news headlines.
很多东西，你知道，你能想象这个吗？就像你在刷手机。你心想，噢，真漂亮，我朋友的照片，名人的照片，小狗的照片，20人死于泥石流。那仍然是进入你大脑的信息。所以那是被动的。第二种类型的末日滚动是主动的末日滚动，这也是当我说末日滚动时，我们通常想到的。这更像是一个不断浏览新闻头条的刻意习惯。
And most of the time, news that isn't very good, because then it wouldn't be noteworthy. I will say, we do have to pay attention to what is going on in the world, and it is important to stay informed. And it's important to know what is happening around you in politics, with the environment, with foreign policy, with human rights. But we can do this in a way that doesn't become crippling. I have a friend Erin, who has been a guest on the show before.
而且大多数时候，这些新闻都不是很好的新闻，因为如果那样的话它就不值得关注了。我要说的是，我们确实需要关注世界上正在发生的事情，保持知情是很重要的。了解你周围在政治、环境、外交政策、人权方面发生的事情是很重要的。但我们可以用一种不会让人崩溃的方式来做这件事。我有一个朋友叫埃琳，她以前曾是节目的嘉宾。
We love Erin. Big friend of the show. And she, I hope she doesn't mind me using this story. I don't think she will. But she is incredibly invested in climate change and in the state and the environment. Like, that's what she does for work. She protects wetlands in Australia, like she goes to protest. She's studying horticulture next year.
我们很喜欢埃琳。节目的老朋友了。她，我希望她不介意我讲这个故事。我想她不会的。但她非常热衷于气候变化以及现状和环境。就像，那是她的工作。她在澳大利亚保护湿地，她去参加抗议活动。她明年还要学习园艺。
She's so passionate. She's so invested. One of the most beautiful souls and most passionate, you know, just souls for these issues. But she was telling me, you know, how dark that can get for her. Because she's so drawn to seeking out further information, as much information as possible about the state of all of these things, about the state of the environment, about what species is going extinct, what government is not protecting which habitat. And it's become a bit of a compulsion needing to find out more, not wanting to be in the dark, and therefore consuming all of the
她太充满热情了。她太投入了。最美丽的灵魂之一，也是对这些问题最有热情的灵魂之一。但她告诉我，你知道，这对她来说会变得多么黑暗。因为她被吸引去寻找更多信息，关于所有这些事情的现状、关于环境的现状、关于哪个物种正在灭绝、哪个政府没有保护哪个栖息地的尽可能多的信息。这已经变成了一种强迫症，需要了解更多，不想被蒙在鼓里，因此日复一日地消费着所有最糟糕的内容和头条新闻。作为她的朋友，你知道，看到这一幕很难受，因为你显然知道她非常在乎。这是她如何关心的一个元素和方面，但这会让人变得非常悲观。我们为什么要这么做？除了只想知道更多这个事实之外，为什么会这样？好吧，第一个原因在于，当我们觉得自己知道得更多时，我们假设这会让我们在未来具备更强的应对能力。所以尽管它很糟糕，但至少我们不是被蒙在鼓里，至少它不是不确定的。
worst content and all of the worst headlines day in and day out. And as her friend, you know, it's very hard to see because you obviously know she cares a lot. And this is an element and an aspect of her of how much she cares but it can make people incredibly pessimistic. Why do we do it? Other than just the fact that we want to know more, why is it? Well, the first reason is that when we feel that we know more, we assume that that's going to make us more equipped in the future. So even though it's terrible, at least we are not in the dark, at least it is not uncertain.
至少我们掌握了所有细节。所以这个解释实际上植根于焦虑。媒体心理学研究中心的一位精神病学家在一个我在研究这期节目时读到的文章中把这一点表达得非常非常准确，他说的是，基本上末日滚动就是当我们在害怕时，试图获得答案的一种强迫性需求。这不仅是一种强迫性需求，这也是一种非常人类的需求，对吧？更多信息，更多细节，这提供了更多的安全感错觉。
at least we have all the details. So this explanation is really based in anxiety. And one psychiatrist from the Media Psychology Research Center, he put it really, really well in an article that I was reading when I was researching this episode, what he said was that basically doom scrolling is just a compulsive need to try and get answers when we're afraid. And not only is it a compulsive need, that's a very human need, right? more information, more details, that provides more of an illusion of security.
所以末日滚动实际上是一种非常扭曲的、黑暗的，而且我认为是反直觉的自我安慰行为。我总是这样想，也许这说不通，但我认为会的。就像你经历分手后，不断查看前任的社交媒体，以确保他们没有和新人在一起，看看他们在关注谁，你想确切知道他们分手后的旅程进展如何，尽管这很痛苦，这和我们在这里做的事情非常相似，因为不了解的另一种假设在我们的脑海里会呈指数级变得更糟。这就是你的焦虑。焦虑，正如我们所知，它喜欢吞噬空白
So doom scrolling is actually this really twisted, dark, and I would say counterintuitive self-soothing behavior. I always think about it like, maybe this won't make sense, I think it will. When you like go through a breakup and you keep checking on your ex's social media to like make sure they're not with someone new to see who they're following, you want to know exactly how their post-relationship journey is going, even though it's painful, that is very similar to what we're doing here, because the alternative hypothetical of not knowing, that is exponentially worse in our brain. And that's anxiety for you. Anxiety, as we know, it loves to feed on the empty
地带。它喜欢吞噬未知。它喜欢吞噬缺乏答案的状态，因为那是它能够进行最多灾难化想象的地方，对吧？那是它能玩得最开心的时候。它是一个相当狡猾的家伙。所以，总结一下，末日滚动就是寻求控制。为了确定性而寻找信息。根据哈佛大学最近的一些研究，这种行为也深深植根于我们大脑的边缘系统。
spaces. It loves to feed on the unknown. It loves to feed on a lack of answers because that is where it can do its most, like the most of its catastrophizing, right? That's when it can have the most fun. It's a pretty sneaky being. So, doom scrolling is just to really wrap that up, it's control seeking. It's information seeking for the sake of certainty. This behavior is also really rooted in our brain's limbic system, according to some recent research at Harvard.
所以你可能以前听说过我们的边缘系统。它基本上是我们的蜥蜴脑。它是我们古老的动物脑，是我们非常古老的一部分。我们的边缘系统促进并负责自我保护。它驱动我们对危险的战斗或逃跑反应。它通常也是推动我们去寻找威胁的动力。你知道，我们正处于高度警惕状态。我们正在利用我们现在拥有的资源（即互联网）扫描危险。
So you've probably heard of our limbic system before. It is basically our lizard brain. It is our like old animal brain, very ancient part of us. And our limbic system is what promotes and is responsible for self-preservation. It drives our fight or flight response to danger. And it is typically what fuels us to scroll for threats. You know, we are being hypervigilant. We are scanning for danger using the resources that we have now, which is the internet.
你刷得越多，你就越觉得自己需要了解更多。根据哈佛的那篇论文，有两个群体比其他人更容易出现这种情况。一个是女性，另一个是有创伤史的人。为什么会这样？这是因为这两个人群对高度警惕的需求根深蒂固。它写在我们的DNA里。它在我们的骨子里。它在我们的记忆中。而且，你知道，这是一个非常，它很迷人，但同时其实也相当具有毁灭性的研究。这是一项针对难民以及最近移民到一个新国家的难民的研究，以及这些社区发生末日滚动的比率。他们发现这个比率要高得多，尤其是当你考虑到，你知道，
And the more you scroll, the more you feel you need to know. There are two groups who are more prone to this than anyone else, according to that same paper from Harvard. It's women and it's people with a history of trauma. Why is that? It's because the need for hypervigilance in those two populations runs deep. It is in our DNA. It is in our bones. It is in our memories. And, you know, there was this really, it was fascinating, but it was also just actually quite devastating. It was a study into refugees and refugees who had recently immigrated to a new country and the rate at which doom scrolling happened in these communities. And what they found was that it was so much higher, especially when you think about, you know,
来自他们祖国的新闻。你知道，他们可能还有家人在那里。他们可能还有亲人在那里。恐惧和对知识的需求实际上延伸到了他们之外。这并不是说新闻业或记者在帮助我们度过难关，哪怕对普通人来说也是如此。他们知道我们更容易被那些能唤起紧迫感和恐惧感的新闻故事所吸引。
news from their home countries. You know, they may still have family there. They may still have loved ones there. And the fear and the need for knowledge really extends beyond them. And it's not like the news industry or journalists are helping us through this, even for the average person. They know that we are more drawn in by news stories. that elicit a sense of urgency and fear.
我们的大脑受过训练，会去关注那些、以及实例、刺激和环境等等，这些都会引发那种情绪反应。所以他们发表更多这样的东西。他们把标题取得更耸人听闻。一切看起来都像是一场灾难。与世界真实面貌的整体图景相比，我们把更多的注意力放在了那上面。
Our brains are trained to pay attention to those, into instances and stimulus and environments and whatever, that is creating that kind of emotional reaction. And so they publish more of that stuff. They make the title more crappy. Everything seems disastrous. And we're paying so much more attention to that compared to the overall picture of what the world is really like.
那么我们为什么要这样做呢？首先，我们这样做是因为一种叫做“负面偏误”的东西。负面偏误基本上是一种认知偏误，由于这种偏误，我们往往比正面信息更关注并记住负面信息，因为这对我们的生存更重要。我们真正看到这一点并且知道它适用于我们在手机上看到的新闻或一般新闻的一种方式，是因为加拿大麦吉尔大学的一些优秀研究人员。所以这些研究人员邀请了一些参与者来到他们的实验室，他们说，
So why do we do this? Well, firstly, we do this because of something called the negativity bias. The negative negativity bias is basically this cognitive bias, whereby we tend to pay more attention and we remember negative information more than positive information because it's more important for our survival. And one way that we are really seeing this and that we know that this applies to news that we see on our phone or just news in general is because of some amazing researchers at McGill in Canada. So these researchers invited some participants to come into their lab and they said,
来到我们的实验室，我们要做一个关于眼球追踪的研究。我们只想看看当看到图像时，你们的眼睛是如何移动的。当然那不是真的。他们想知道的是，我们是否会自动地、立即地被好消息、中性新闻或坏消息吸引，还是都一样？这难道只是，你知道，我们的大脑，从头到尾的大脑扫描吗？所以，基本上他们让这些人进到一个房间里，然后说，噢，你知道，在我们进入实际实验之前，随便挑一些你想在等待时阅读的新闻文章，你可以随便浏览一下。然后他们被要求阅读这些文章，他们是否真的阅读其实并不重要，这只是一种装样子的手段，接着他们进行了研究，他们发现的
come into our lab, we're going to do this study on eye tracking. We just want to see like how your eyes move in response to images. Of course that's not true. What they wanted to know was are we automatically and immediately drawn more to good news, neutral news or bad news or is it just all the same? Is it just, you know, our brains, our brain scans from top to bottom? So, basically they had these people in a room and they were like oh you know before we like get into the actual experiment just pick like some news articles that you want to read while you wait like you can just have a little browse they were then asked to read them it didn't really matter if they actually read them it was just kind of like to keep up appearances and then they did the study and what they
结果是，压倒性的是，当他们拿到这个网站并且有等量的负面、正面和中性故事时。压倒性地，我们的眼睛首先去的地方是最可怕、最负面、最令人沮丧的头条新闻，关于腐败、死亡、自然灾害的事情，而不是中性故事。当事后问他们时，这是这项研究中非常有趣的第二个组成部分，当他们说，好吧，你觉得如今的新闻，是好消息多，坏消息多，还是中性消息多，你知道吗？几乎所有人都觉得，噢，不，现在的新闻太糟糕了，目前所有事情都在出错，你知道的，
found was that overwhelmingly when they were given this site and there was an equal amount of negative positive and neutral stories. Overwhelmingly, the place our eyes go to first were the most scary, negative, distressing headlines, things about corruption, death, natural disasters, and not the neutral stories. And when they asked them afterwards, and this is the second component to this study that is so interesting, when they said, okay, do you think that the news these days, is it more good, is it more bad, is it more, you know, neutral? almost all of them were like oh no the news is so bad everything is going so wrong at the moment you know
我在那个新闻网站上看到的大多数故事都是负面的，尽管它们实际上完全对半开。我们抓住负面信息不放，是因为它新颖，因为它值得关注，并且因为我们认为它更重要。我认为每当你浏览澳大利亚广播公司（ABC）、《卫报》、《纽约时报》或任何网站时，意识到这一点非常重要。我认为并非一切都那么糟糕，但我们被外部力量（如主流媒体）和内部力量（如我们的负面偏误）所欺骗，从而相信了这一点。在探讨我们如何停止它之前，我想给出最后一个解释，说明我们为什么会这样做。这其实归结为社交媒体应用设计的心理学。
the majority of the stories i saw on that news site were negative despite the fact that it was completely even we grab onto negative information because it is novel because it is noteworthy and because we think that it's more important i think this is really important to be aware of whenever you're surfing like the abc or the guardian or the new york times or whatever it is I think that it's not all bad, but we are tricked by both external forces like the mainstream media, but also internal forces like our negativity bias into believing so. I want to give you one final explanation as to why before we go into how we can stop it. And it actually comes down to the psychology of how social media apps are designed.
这并不令人意外。社交媒体是让人上瘾的。可能也不令人意外。它就是这样被制造出来的，因为你的注意力就是金钱。这就是这些应用程序的整个商业模式。他们越能吸引你的注意力，你从广告中购买的东西就越多。所以，如果你发现自己很难设定
No surprises here. Social media is addictive. probably also not a surprise. It was made that way because your attention is money. That's the whole business model of these apps. The more they can keep your attention, the more that you will buy things from ads. So it's really, don't beat yourself up if you find it really hard to set
这些数字边界，不要太自责。就像他们正在尽一切努力确保这种情况不会发生一样。我记得Instagram和Facebook在某个阶段，我读过一篇文章，讲到他们甚至在薪酬名单上、团队里聘请了真正的神经科学家，他们是带薪员工，他们的工作基本上就是，告诉我们如何能让人上瘾。其中一种他们提出的方法，
those digital boundaries. Like they are doing everything in their power to make sure that doesn't happen. Instagram and Facebook actually, I remember at one stage, I read an article about how they had literal neuroscientists, on their payroll, on their teams, they were paid employees, and their job was basically like, tell us how we can keep people hooked. And one of the ways that they were like, hey, this is a way
就是所谓的无限滚动。这在我们进行末日滚动的原因中起着非常重要的作用。所以无限滚动意味着我们永远不会用完可看的内容。我记得在早期，比如2010年代初期，Instagram刚发布的时候，大约是2013年、2014年。你会打开Instagram，当所有人都，当你把所有内容都看完了，基本上你所关注的每个人都在过去五天内发过帖子而且你看过了，页面就会到头。就像你再也无法往下翻了。你会撞上一堵墙。而现在，不，不，不。那不会发生。
you can do this, is called the Infinite Scroll. And this plays a really important part in why we doomscroll. So the Infinite Scroll means that we are never going to run out of content to see. I remember like back in the day in like the early like 2010s when Instagram was first released like 2013, 2014. You would go on Instagram and when everybody, when you'd seen everything, when basically you'd, everyone that you followed had posted within the last five days and you'd seen it, it would just be the end of the screen. Like you couldn't go any further. You would hit like a wall. And nowadays, no, no, no. That is not happening.
那绝对不会发生。他们不希望你退出应用程序。他们希望你留在应用里。所以你会开始看到推荐内容。你会开始看到所有其他你未必关注的内容，但你依然沉迷其中，因为这就像大量多巴胺涌入你的大脑。这是心灵的垃圾食品。我这个隐喻用得相当字面。
That is not happening. They do not want you to exit the app. They want you to stay on the app. And so you'll start seeing recommended content. You'll start seeing all this other stuff that you're not necessarily following, but you stay hooked because it's just like all this dopamine flooding into your brain. It's junk food for the mind. And I say this metaphor quite literally.
我们喂养大脑的信息，就像我们喂养身体的食物一样，真的很重要。你会成为你大脑接收内容的产物，而这确实会影响你的世界观。如果你是一个末日滚动者，我也包括在内。所以这里没有任何批评。但如果你是一个末日滚动者，你接收到的东西将是悲观的、暗淡的。这会导致大量的焦虑，大量的冷漠。比如，天哪，谁在乎呢？这个世界太糟糕了。它会导致大量的存在主义焦虑，比如觉得世界毫无意义，生命究竟意味着什么。它还会给我们带来一种我们称之为“爆米花大脑”的东西，我不知道你最近有没有听说过，你以后会听到更多关于它的消息，但……我读了
The information that we feed our brains, just like what we feed our body, it really matters. You become a product of what your brain is receiving and that really influences your worldview. you. And if you are a doomscroller, I'm included in that. So there is no criticism here. But if you are a doom scroller, what you're receiving is going to be pessimistic and it's going to be bleak. And that results in a lot of anxiety, a lot of like apathy. Like, oh my God, who cares? Like the world is just so terrible. It results in a lot of existential anxiety, which is like a sense that like the world is just, there's no point what does life even mean it can also give us something that we call popcorn brain i don't know if you've heard about this recently you will be hearing about it more in the future but um i read
另一篇文章，我想是在耶鲁大学或哈佛大学的杂志上，记不清了，如果我找到了会随时向你汇报，但基本上这篇文章说，当你花太多时间上网时，“爆米花大脑”就会发生，你的大脑对信息的刺激过于饱和，以至于感觉它快要爆裂了。它感觉受到了过度的刺激，你会觉得，啪，啪，就像你从一件事转移到另一件事，然后速度非常快，非常快。这并不正常，这使得与现实世界进行互动变得非常困难，并且让我们感到非常焦虑，对世界感到焦虑和麻木是不正常的，这不是我认为我们应该将其常态化，也不是我认为应该定义我们生活的东西。幸运的是，就像我们陷入
another article i think either in uh Yale or harvard magazine can't remember i'll keep you updated if i find it but basically this article is like popcorn brain happens when you spend too much time online and your brain is like actually so overstimulated with information that it almost feels like it's popping. It feels so overstimulated that you're like pop, pop, like you're moving from one thing to another and like it's just fast and fast and fast. That is not normal and that makes it really hard to engage with the real world and it makes us feel really anxious and feeling anxious and numb about the world is not normal and it's not something that I think we should normalize and it's not something that I think should define our life. Luckily though, the same way that we get
末日滚动的循环一样，我们也可以摆脱它，我们可以找到一种与我们的新闻、我们的内容、我们的手机等建立健康关系的方式。在短暂的广告休息之后，我想聊聊我们如何才能找到出路，以及能让我们达到那一步的行为和心理转变。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、体能和韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和体能专家等人进行对话，
trapped in a doom scrolling cycle, we can also get out of it and we can find a way to have a healthy relationship with our news, with our content, with our phones, whatever it is. So I want to talk about how we can find our way out and the kind of behavioral and mental shifts that can get us there after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more,
以看穿主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到惊恐的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上搜索 TWO percent。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们的主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师科尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将把我在心理健康领域超过十年的经验以及与社交界人士的对话带给大家。
to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with social.
这么多不可思议的嘉宾。我在说。特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时候，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于投入追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了这样东西。而我们仍在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候才算足够。
so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough.
因为人们在盯着记分牌。生活变得只剩下赢与输。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯。因为你觉得在这个地球上做一个好人很重要？还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两个不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。
Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
绝对的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能够真正地做一个好人。加入我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是科尔·盖恩斯，我们一起探讨关于治愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio App。搜索 Learn the Hard Way 并立即收听。2023年，前《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开始了长达数年的法律战来证明真相。欧文斯女士，这份特定的检测报告你伪造过两次，对吗？我伪造了一次检测报告。
Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones.
这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案件。我希望人们能看到他们的税款被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。
It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
这是 Love Trapped。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这还没结束。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听 Love Trapped 播客。女士们先生们，每个男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。规则一，永远不要惹乡下女孩。
This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl.
玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖励。规则二，也永远不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。我是安娜·西恩菲尔德，在这个新季的《女朋友们》中，天啊，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这种事怎么会发生在我身上？
You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me?
警察似乎并不关心。所以她们决定自己采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼，不。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的。收听《女朋友们》。相信我，宝贝。
The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe.
在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。我只想快速重复我之前说过的话，因为我认为这是一个非常重要的观点。你仍然可以了解情况，知道发生了什么，并且不沉迷于负面新闻循环。你可以兼得。你仍然可以承认世界有时是严酷而残酷的，并且感到快乐、喜悦、感恩，
On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I'm just going to quickly repeat what I said before because I think it's a really important point. You can still be informed and know what's going on and not be addicted to the negative news cycle. You can have both. you can still acknowledge that the world is harsh and cruel at times and feel happy, joyful, grateful,
不是尽管如此，而是正因如此。一切可能看起来更……你会成为让某人今天不这样认为的原因。你会为世界注入更多一点和谐、更多一点和平、更多一点善良。几个月前，大约六个月前，这对我帮助很大。我在当时的播客中讨论过这件事，但我对社交媒体消费产生了一种相当沉重黑暗的心态。根据我所看到的和我收到的评论，我确信每个人都很恶劣。
not despite of it, but in spite of it. Everything might seem more for well. You are going to be the reason that someone doesn't think that today. You are going to pour a little bit more harmony, a little bit more peace, a little bit more kindness into the world. And this is something that really helped me a few months back, maybe like six months ago. and I discussed it on the podcast at the time, but I got into a pretty heavy dark headspace around my social media consumption. And I was just convinced based on what I was seeing and the comments that I was receiving that everyone was just me.
不是尽管如此，而是正因如此。一切可能看起来更好。你将成为让某人今天免于那种想法的原因。你将为世界注入更多的一点和谐、更多的一点平静、更多的一点善良。这正是几个月前真正帮助过我的事情，大概是六个月前。我当时在播客中讨论过这件事，但我因为社交媒体的使用陷入了一种相当沉重黑暗的心境。根据我所看到的以及我收到的评论，我当时确信每个人都在针对我。
Everyone was just judgmental. It was everywhere. And I know now I was selectively paying attention to what was confirming my bias. But one of the ways that I got out of this was really starting to leave positivity where I saw negativity. If I saw a bunch of trolls, you know, I'd make sure to comment something nice, that kind of thing. It's all about diluting the bad, sad, downright depressing stuff with a little bit of light, like drop by drop. You know, imagine that you have a full glass of wine and it's red and, you know, it's very hard to see through, murky. And then you put it under a tap and you keep the tap on slowly that wine glass is diluted.
每个人都很喜欢评判，这种现象无处不在。我现在知道，我当时是有选择性地关注那些印证我偏见的事情。但摆脱这种状态的方法之一，就是开始在看到消极的地方留下积极的能量。如果我看到一堆喷子，你知道的，我会确保留下一条友善的评论之类的。这就像是用一点微光，一滴一滴地去冲淡那些糟糕的、悲伤的、甚至是令人沮丧的事情。你知道的，想象一下你有一满杯红酒，它颜色很深，非常浑浊，很难看透。然后你把它放在水龙头下，让水慢慢流着，这杯酒就被稀释了。
And the water going into that wine glass, that is your kindness when it seems really, really gloomy. part of why it seems so is because we feel like we can't do anything about it. We feel like we can't fix the world's problems. And at times that's true. You can't fix the whole world. But you can fix your circle. You can fix your part of the universe, your little corner of the world, by doing it kind to people, doing it really, really rough,
流入酒杯里的水，就是当一切看起来非常、非常暗淡时你展现出的善良。它之所以看起来如此糟糕，部分原因是我们觉得自己对此无能为力。我们觉得我们无法解决世界上的问题。有时确实如此。你无法拯救整个世界。但你可以管好你自己的圈子。你可以通过对别人好一点、做一些真正脚踏实地的事情，来修复你那一部分的宇宙、你世界里的小角落，
by donating to charity, by donating your time, by cooking for your elderly neighbors, by planting native plants in your garden or on your balcony. That is the most beautiful way in my mind to counteract a mindset that says the world is fucked based on doom scrolling. It's to say, yeah, the world is fucked, but where I am, what I choose to do, I'm not going to be a representation of that. Just because the news is bad doesn't mean that I'm going to take that and mean that I'm going to make it worse. You know, I have a friend who has her garden filled with flowers just for her honeybees. And it's just one of the first things I do when I go over to her house. Like she has these poppies that are like specifically for honeybees, bumblebees, whatever you call them.
比如向慈善机构捐款，捐出你的时间，为年迈的邻居做饭，或者在你的花园或阳台上种植本土植物。在我看来，这是对抗那种基于“刷负面新闻”而认为世界已经完蛋的心态的最美妙的方式。那就是去说，是的，世界是完蛋了，但在我所在的地方，在我选择做的事情上，我不会成为那种现象的缩影。仅仅因为新闻很糟糕，并不意味着我要全盘接受，并不意味着我要让情况变得更糟。你知道的，我有个朋友，她的花园里种满了鲜花，专门留给她的蜜蜂。每次我去她家，这都是我做的第一件事。她有一些专门为蜜蜂、大黄蜂之类昆虫准备的虞美人。
And I love checking on her bees. It's just like so pretty. And it's just like, oh, there is something that's alive. There is something that's good. My friend has honeybees in her backyard. Like, yay. That's a great new story in my life. You can also really help yourself break the toxic negative cycle that contributes to doom scrolling by rethinking the content.
我特别喜欢去查看她的蜜蜂。那画面太美了。就会觉得，哦，还有生命在延续。还有美好的事物存在。我的朋友在后院养了蜜蜂。太棒了。这是我生活中一个很棒的新闻故事。通过重新审视你看到的内容，你也可以真正帮助自己打破导致“刷负面新闻”的恶性循环。
by rethinking the content that you see. You know, make a conscious decision to start following positive news sites or newsletters or pages. That is like you diluting the negative news. I love, for example, the good news movement, which started during the pandemic to kind of counteract the very thing that we are talking about today, which is doom scrolling. I also like the dodo. It's not really news. It's just animal stories.
通过重新审视你所看到的内容。你知道的，做一个有意识的决定，开始关注积极的新闻网站、新闻简报或网页。这就好比你在稀释负面新闻。比如我非常喜欢“好消息运动”（Good News Movement），它是在大流行期间发起的，旨在对抗我们今天正在讨论的“刷负面新闻”现象。我也喜欢“渡渡鸟”（The Dodo）。它其实算不上新闻，只是动物的故事。
That's it. It's just really cute animals. stories and you know what it's really delightful to see the good news network is also another really really good one positive news.com you know you are not limiting yourself you are diluting it you have to start showing your mind giving your mind healthy examples that it's not all bad even if that remains your prevailing emotion for a while part of getting out of that headspace is really offering alternative information and evidence to our brain feeding it well, feeding it with nutritious information, making sure that your diet isn't just rich,
就这些。里面全是非常可爱的动物故事，你知道的，看到这些真的让人很高兴。“好消息网络”（Good News Network）也是另一个非常、非常棒的网站，还有 positivenews.com。你知道的，你不是在限制自己，你是在稀释它。你必须开始向你的大脑展示、给你的大脑提供健康的例子，让它知道并非一切都是糟糕的，即使这种糟糕的情绪在一段时间内仍然是你的主导情绪。摆脱那种心理状态的过程之一，就是真正为我们的大脑提供替代信息和证据，很好地滋养它，用有营养的信息喂养它，确保你的饮食不仅丰富，
your media diet isn't just rich in all of this really intense information. And that's the only thing that you're giving your brain. It's also really important to have balance there. And I'm going to carry on the metaphor of food and eating and feeding, but having a balanced informational diet. And this was something that was introduced to me by someone I interviewed recently who's coming on for our December 12 days of guests. I won't spoil who it is, but she was talking about how you can't just give yourself
你的媒体饮食不仅充满了所有这些强烈的信息，而且这些信息是你提供给你大脑的全部内容。保持平衡也很重要。我要延续食物、饮食和滋养的比喻，那就是拥有均衡的信息饮食。这是我最近采访的一位嘉宾向我介绍的，她将作为我们12月12天嘉宾活动的出场嘉宾。我不剧透她是谁，但她当时在谈论你不能只给自己提供
one source of news or information. That is what gets us stuck in informational bubbles. That's what gets us stuck in, you know, only seeing the world in a certain way, not being able to think about other people's opinions. And it also means that we're only going to see a negative perspective from one side of things. So having a few newspapers that you read, having your news papers that you read, having your news, podcast, but then also including something bright, something less serious, having some fiction,
单一来源的新闻或信息。那正是让我们陷入信息茧房的原因。那正是让我们陷入只能以某种特定方式看待世界、无法思考他人观点的状态的原因。这也意味着我们将只能看到事物某一面的负面视角。所以，要阅读几份不同的报纸，阅读你的报纸，收听你的新闻播客，但同时也要包含一些轻松的、不那么严肃的内容，比如阅读一些小说，
having like a fun book that you're reading on the side, something less serious. That is a really important way to diversify what you are consuming so that it doesn't just all become stale and all become one way. Now I also want to turn to kind of like curtailing or rethinking our social media habits because I think this is a huge culprit in passive doom scrolling. this is one we really need to zoom in on you know if we're going to talk about how to stop doom scrolling we can't talk about that without talking about how to be have a healthier usage of social media and i'll start with one of my favorite reminders for how to do this if you want to
比如在空闲时读一本有趣的书，一些不那么严肃的东西。这是使你所消费的内容多样化的一种非常重要的方法，这样它们就不会变得死气沉沉、千篇一律。现在我还想谈谈如何减少或重新审视我们的社交媒体习惯，因为我认为这是导致被动“刷负面新闻”的罪魁祸首。这是我们需要真正深入探讨的问题，你知道的，如果我们讨论如何停止“刷负面新闻”，我们就不能不谈论如何更健康地使用社交媒体。我先从我最喜欢的关于如何做到这一点的提醒开始：如果你想
change anything you have to start by changing how that thing shows up in your routine you cannot just think your way into a happier mental state you can't say you know yeah it'd be nice to like control my social media. Really wish I would get to that and then not do that because it's just, I've tried it. It doesn't work. You're not going to do it. I think one of the big reasons that we have a negative relationship with social media and the news is because we let it be in control rather than having good mental hygiene habits. And yes, I did say hygiene because that is how I like to see it. You know, you wash your face every night, you brush your teeth, hopefully, please do that. You know, you wash your towels, you shower, you take care of yourself physically. Now it's time to apply those
改变任何事情，你都必须从改变该事物在你的日常作息中出现的方式开始。你不能仅仅靠空想来进入一种更快乐的精神状态。你不能说“哦，如果能控制我的社交媒体就好了，我真希望自己能做到这一点”，然后却什么都不做，因为我试过了，这根本没用。你根本不会去做的。我认为我们与社交媒体和新闻关系恶化的主要原因之一，是我们让它们反客为主，而不是保持良好的心理卫生习惯。是的，我用了“卫生”这个词，因为我就是这样看待它的。你知道的，你每天晚上洗脸，刷牙——希望如此，请一定要刷牙——你知道的，你洗毛巾，洗澡，在身体上照顾好自己。现在是时候将这些
same hygiene routines to taking care of yourself mentally, specifically in terms of your relationship with your phone. So here are some tried and tested measures for having better social media hygiene, better mental hygiene. Right off the bat, phone off before bed. Your phone cannot be the last thing you see before you sleep and it definitely cannot be the first. thing that you see when you wake up in the morning because that just means that you are literally plugged in day and night there is never a break the moment you are conscious you're consuming content the moment before you are unconscious you're consuming content so sleep with it in a separate room and just buy an alarm clock because I know that's a big reason why a lot of people are like oh I have to have
同样的卫生习惯应用到照顾你的心理健康上，特别是针对你与手机的关系。所以，这里有一些经过时间考验的方法，可以让你拥有更好的社交媒体卫生和更好的心理卫生。开门见山地说：睡觉前关掉手机。在睡觉前你看到的最后一样东西绝对不能是手机，当你早晨醒来时，它也绝对不能是你看到的第一样东西，因为那意味着你实际上日夜连线，从来没有休息过。你清醒的那一刻就在消费内容，你在失去意识前的最后一刻也在消费内容。所以，把手机放在另一个房间睡觉，去买个闹钟吧，因为我知道这是很多人说“哦，我必须把手机放在房间里，因为我要用它当闹钟”的主要原因。去你当地的杂货店，去你当地的2元店，去脸书市场上找一个闹钟，一个老式的闹钟，然后开始用它代替手机。你会看到惊人的改变。我以前没意识到，把手机放在床头柜旁边让我感到了多么严重的焦虑。我做的另一件事是，在看手机之前，我早上先做一件事。显然我是为自己工作的，所以有一种强烈的倾向，这是我需要改掉的最有毒的坏习惯，我在这方面做得很差，呃……
my phone in my room because my alarm go to like your local reject shop go to your local I don't know a two dollar store go to your local go on Facebook marketplace find an alarm clock like a good old fashioned alarm clock and start using that instead you will just see amazing changes i didn't realize how anxious i was by having my phone just right next to my bedside and the other thing that i did was i started doing one thing in the morning before i went on my phone obviously i work for myself so there is this like big tendency and it's like the most toxic habit bad habit that i need to break i'm very bad at it um But I'm getting there slowly.
但我正在慢慢改进。那就是在看手机之前，我先做别的事情。我先做别的事情，这样我就不会去查邮件。当然，一旦我查了邮件，我就会刷社交媒体。当然，一旦我刷了社交媒体，突然之间，过去一夜之间发生的事情——比如在美国、英国或世界其他地方，因为我住在澳大利亚——就会彻底把世界撕裂。所以这一点真的非常、非常重要。社交媒体计时器，我觉得它们并不总是管用，因为你随时都可以
And it's that before I go on my phone, I do something else. I do something else so that I don't check my emails. And of course, once I check my emails, I check my social media. And of course, once I check my social media, suddenly there is something that has happened overnight, like in the US or in the UK or across the world because I live in Australia that is like completely, you know, torn the world apart. So that is really, really important. Social media timers, I don't think they always work because you can just just
把它们关掉。我是怎么解决这个问题的呢？在工作日期间，即上午10点到下午4点之间，我实际上会把社交媒体从手机里删掉。我当然会有这种冲动。我甚至发现自己会拿起手机去刷社交媒体，或者漫无目的地乱翻，或者查看新闻网站。但因为增加了一层难度——我必须把这些应用重新下载到手机里——我就会想：“算了吧，我还是别干了。”然后我就克制住了自己。这就好比我创造了一个质疑的契机，一个转折点，让我不得不思考：“我真的想这么做吗？大概不想吧。”
kind of dismiss them. How I get around that is that I actually delete my social media from my phone between 10am to 4 p.m. during the week. I definitely have the urge. And I even notice that like I go to pick up my phone to like check my social media or to like aimlessly scroll or to like check like a new site. But because there is that additional level of difficulty, like I would have to read download those apps onto my phone. I'm like, I'm just not going to do that. And I stop myself. it's like I have created this like point of questioning, this point of inflection where I have to be like, ooh, do I actually want to do that? Probably not.
我在一天的早些时候就做出了一个有意识的决定，今天不让自己这样做。我不想违背自己的决定。出去散步吧。这也是一种很好的方式，能让人感觉没那么沉重，去到户外，回到我们本该身处的环境中去。这样我们就会觉得自己更像个人，去体验那些让我们成为人类、让我们成为这个自然的生物的感官刺激。新鲜空气，树木的味道，看到大自然，看到其他人。
I made a conscious decision earlier in the day to not let myself do this today. I don't want to go against her. Go for a walk instead. That's a great way as well just to feel a little bit less weighed down as being outside and returning to the environments that we are meant to be in. So we feel more human. and we experience the sensations that make us human and make us natural creatures of this environment. You know, fresh air, the smell of the trees, seeing nature, seeing other people.
当你被与新闻相关的焦虑、挫折感和悲观情绪压得喘不过气来时，这一点至关重要。你必须抽身出来。你必须退后一步。你必须走进大自然。你必须去户外的环境中，离开那个空间，只是呼吸，体验你的感官，然后断网一段时间。你知道的，这不仅仅是你个人的问题。这是一些严重的、急剧的社会变革所导致的结果。
That is so important when you are feeling crippled by anxiety and frustration and angst to do with the news. You've got to clock out. You've got to take a step back. You've got to go into nature. You've got to go into an outdoor environment. leave the space and just breathe, experience your senses, and disconnect for a while. You know, this is not just a you issue. This is the result of some serious rapid societal shifts.
就像生活的改变一样，就像整个世界在过去几年里变化得非常快。你知道的，我们的父母从来不用担心“刷负面新闻”的问题。也许他们需要担心看新闻的时间太长，但你知道的，新闻只播两个小时，他们不得不看，我不知道，比如《布雷迪 Bunch》（Brady Bunch）。我不知道那时候播什么，就当是《布雷迪 Bunch》吧。所以，你知道的，这对我们来说是一个日益严重的问题。
And just like changing life of, like just the whole world is changing very quickly in the past few years. You know, our parents never had to worry about doom scrolling. Maybe they had to worry about watching the news for too long. but, you know, only went for two hours, that they had to watch, I don't know, Brady Bunch. I don't know what was on back then, Brady Bunch, that we're going to go with that. So, you know, it is an increasing problem for us.
我们是第一代必须寻找与它更健康关系的人，我们不知道没有网络的生活是怎样的。我还想说，去订一份报纸吧。我在墨尔本生活时曾这么做过一段时间。我会让人把报纸送到家里。一想到我们现在还能这么做，就觉得非常、非常不可思议，但他们确实还提供这项服务。这意味着我的新闻不仅是有选择性的，而且不只是来自我的手机。有些方法可以解决这个问题，有些方法可以让我们保持知情，但又不会被压垮，不会整天感到恐惧，
We are the first generation that has had to find a healthier relationship with it, who doesn't know life without it. I will say also get a newspaper. I did this for a while when I was, like, living in Melbourne. I would get my newspaper delivered. super, super strange to think that we could do that still, but they do still offer that service. And it meant that my news wasn't only selective and it wasn't only coming from my phone. There are ways around this and there are ways to be aware, but not overwhelmed and not fearful all
也不会感到彻底的沮丧。我认为“刷负面新闻”这种现象，如果你想控制它，你就必须控制“刷”的部分，你必须控制你与手机的关系，以及那种想要寻求更多信息的焦虑需求，因为它对你毫无帮助，也无法带来更好的结果。所以希望这能成为你重新审视这些习惯所需的鼓励。我当然希望你能觉得自己并不孤单，我就和你在一起。你知道那个统计数据是什么吗？51%的Z世代年轻人（也就是20多岁的人）正在经历“刷负面新闻”带来的影响。所以，如果你的数码习惯和想要了解资讯的需求有点失控，也无需感到羞耻。你知道的，我不愿意承认这比完全不了解
the time and not just quite frankly depressed. And I think doom scrolling, if you want to manage it, you have to manage the scrolling part. and you have to manage your relationship with your phone and that anxious need to seek out more information because it's not helping you and it's not leading to a better outcome so hope this has been the encouragement you need to rethink those practices i most certainly hope that you feel less alone i'm there with you a lot of you know what was the statistic 51% of people in gen c so people in their 20s are experiencing the effects of doom scrolling so there is no shame if your digital habits and your need to be informed getting out of hand. You know, I hate to say it's better than not being
情况要好，尽管这种感觉糟糕透顶。而且你已经做得很好了。你已经具备了想要了解更多的同理心。现在是时候对你自己展现同理心了，在你的日常生活中留出一些空间，真正能够去消化这一切，并去体验生活。所以，如果你喜欢这一集，和往常一样，请随时在苹果播客、Spotify或你现在收听节目的任何地方留下五星好评。确保你一直在关注我们，“12天嘉宾”活动即将到来，那是我们的12月档期，我们将连续12天推出嘉宾访集，嘉宾都是我非常喜欢的一些人，我有幸能采访他们，所以你绝对不想错过其中的任何一集。
informed at all, even if it feels terrible. And you've already got that down pat. You've already got the empathy to want to know more. Now it is time to have the empathy for yourself, to have some space in your day, to actually just be able to process it all and to be able to experience life. So if you enjoyed this episode, as always, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now. make sure you are following along 12 days of guests is coming up that is our December period where we just do 12 days of guest episodes with like some of my favorite people who I get the privileged to interview so you don't want to miss any of
确保你在Instagram上关注我们，账号是@thatpsychology1podcast。直到下次再见，注意安全，保持善良，请对你自己温柔一点，谢谢大家，我们很快就会再聊。这是当旁边有自动扶梯时，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。欢迎收听我的播客《2%》。我在这里剖析坚韧精神、健身以及在我们这个奇特的现代世界中建立心理韧性的科学。经历一些磨难，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的自己。
those make sure that you are following us on Instagram at that psychology podcast and until next time stay safe stay kind be gentle with yourself please and thank you and we will talk very very soon That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
收听《2%》。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取个人播客的任何地方搜索TWA%。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）来说都是一个重大的时刻，84年对我来说也很重大。我是萨姆·杰伊（Sam Jay）。
Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your personal. Podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English.
每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何在朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家的陪伴下挺过那段时光的。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论80年代一样。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。
Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it, with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to Look Back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you Get your podcasts.
嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听《艰难学到的教训》（Learn the Hardway），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯（Kare Games）。这个节目探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何其他地方都不太安全去进行的坦诚对话，而你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士一起探讨这些。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kare Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional
有多少男人穿着一身盔甲？它向世界释放的信号是：你可不是好惹的。但这仅仅意味着你有这种能力，并不代表你非得这么做。在AHA广播应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难学到的教训》。
who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app,
在2023年，《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）被指控生下双胞胎，但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。奥恩斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的检测结果两次，对吗？我伪造了一次检测。这需要一大批互联网侦探
Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins, but the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives
来揭露一个令人不安的模式。还有两个男人经历过同样的事情。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我的天啊，我太震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·奥恩斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。
to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一个IHeart播客。真人保证。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这就是全部内容。